what is going on everybody welcome to
the fifth TV basics with python tutorial
video in this video we're going to just
be slowly adding upon the last video so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
call this now simple key VIII's TV 3
save that and my referenced kv file will
be simple key v 3 here ok so let's just
run that make sure I did everything
correctly I did
fancy that ok so like I was saying
before what if for example you've got
let's do a stick button here so we've
got widgets button and then you've got
we see here we have a font size 40 font
size 40 well what if we did this like
font size 40 ok that's fine so I'm going
to cut this and now will come here and
let's say button as the parent :
1 2 3 4 paste font size 40 whoops 40
save that let's run that now and you can
see now we've got size 40 on both
buttons but we didn't have to specify
that because we're using now a parent
button so we could do the same thing
again uh let's say size will cut that
loose paste that position needs to be
you know custom and then you know color
could be the same as well I like green
better so we're going to do good and
we'll get rid of color and we'll get rid
of size so now we just have position in
text for example so save that and we can
run this up they've run into each other
I guess it would be the position screwed
up let's go back over I don't know what
I was thinking yeah okay so so position
this one needs to be 170 Save
there we go so TV tutorials fancy okay
so we can kind of see now hopefully that
where the power of these key V the key
using the key V language can come in is
where we have kind of like these global
variables and of course you can you can
kind of do this within the Python script
as well so it would be a little messier
than doing it this way but you can you
can do that and so a lot of it is just
going to depend how much dynamic code do
you want how much kind of structure do
you want and all this kind of stuff so
anyways that's that the only other thing
I'd like to do now is let's let's talk
about position and we're going to talk
about a little bit of relative
positioning so for example what we could
do is we've you know size that's totally
fine
size though size could be a bit of a
function as well but what we're going to
do a position for now so let's say we
wanted to position something a near the
top so how might we do that well let's
do with TV and let's say um let's say we
want it a position will do route dot X
comma routes dot top um and this is let
me have to do - cell dot
height ok let's save that run that make
sure that works and then I'll explain
what's happening okay so we've got key V
now right at the top and key viewable or
should at least remain at the top as we
resize the window and sure enough it
does and the window has changed
obviously we can also see tutorials
moves as well but anyways closing out of
this let's explain what's happened here
okay so what's happening here is you've
got root X that's referencing the X of
the root right so the root widget which
would or the root app rather which would
be simple TV you know app right that's
our root class and then root dot top is
referencing the top
of that app and then self dot Hyatt is
referencing the self of widgets right
self is that specific widget and we're
referencing the height like I was saying
before so 0 0 is the bottom left so if
you positioned a button at 0 0 or let's
say at let's say the window is 100
pixels tall and you position the element
at 0 100 that is the top-left corner of
that window but then the button is drawn
above that point so the button would be
off the screen so we use minus self dot
height uh to move that buttons you know
bottom left down the height of the
button which is actually referencing
here the 75 so anyway that's how that's
what's going on there so that's a little
more dynamic of code and also kind of
shows what I was telling you before that
you can put some Python logic on the
other side of these colons so anyways
that's going to conclude this this
tutorial video if you guys have any
questions or comments please feel free
to leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions until next
time